do you have time to date sometimes i
just have to remind myself that life's
all good
i hope to uh get married have kids
maybe adopt kids how do you describe
your sound today
you can expect somebody that's probably
going through a lot of the same things
that you are and not be somebody that
tries to sugarcoat my life and make it
seem like something it's not
is it a goal to win a grammy it sounds
crazy but i really do think at some
point it will happen
you did not rest during this quarantine
you have delivered
quite a bit of music including the
release of your
latest single called for real i don't
know
do you describe it i think it's just
questioning everything that we've been
told to accept
the music video is based off the truman
show that's one of my favorite movies of
all time
and i think what stuck out to me about
that movie so much was the fact that
for a while he didn't know that he was
inside a simulated reality
and sometimes this reality feels real
but
some great minds like elon musk and
people like that have questioned the
idea of could this be a simulation
the whole goal of this is for me is to
just
show people that hey i have bad days i
question reality too
i i'm going through the exact same thing
as everybody else
totally and that's that's very
refreshing to hear because i think a lot
of your
millions of supporters online they see
that you are
jacob sartorious and you have this big
life and this huge presence but
when you watch the music video for your
new single and then you you
listen to the lyrics you know i i want
to give you a little piece of my heart
what was on your heart when you were
writing this song
my whole life i think i've battled with
the idea of being
like honest about my feelings like if
i'm feeling depressed for example
sometimes it's hard to express that and
this was a lyric that was just like
it's a way of like getting through the
day you know i lie lie tell everybody
that i'm fine
even though i'm dead like it just shows
that through your actions you can show
people they'll think you're fine
uh because of what you've told them but
we really don't know much about what's
going on inside people's
heads i think that that was the whole
idea on instagram everybody looks real
happy
you know i was adopted i've been through
severe bullying i've been through
relationships and throughout all that
the fame the like the cyber bullying
it blends together and it can really
wreck people
you're sitting in front of me you're
smiling you're obviously really proud of
this new project
how do you overcome all of those awful
things that you just
went down the list to get to the place
where you are today
that's a great question um
ah i think it's about accepting like
the people that we were in the past and
and loving them
you know i was i was hurt for a long
time and i didn't really know how to
process that i kind of took a year off
of
making music and this whole like stuff i
kind of disappeared but
um i really worked on myself and i think
that yeah going through
processing it i think the main thing
that helps me is just
remembering that we're all just human i
do want to talk to you about a specific
lyric
you're always getting high maybe that's
the reason why
and of course that comes on the heels of
your previous release
youtube and barbecue chips
[Music]
how did this become a heavy theme in
your music
well um i just would like to say
youtube in barbecue chips was not
supposed to be like an
only weed song it was supposed to just
be like a real
escape and like kind of a funny song
that wasn't
taken too seriously yeah it was the
first song i dropped as an independent
artist
it was really like somewhat of a like
joke
just having fun of course people will
look deeper into it but
you know that's not what is driving the
music that's not
an intention you made a tick tock about
it the other day people are like jacob
do you still get high i'm like
yeah of course i'm spreading kindness
you know i'm
i'm a troll it's just about how people
want to
internalize it for themselves but i'll
just do me write the music
about real life experiences and that's a
that's up to everybody else it's been i
think about like a year and a half
almost two years since you dropped your
last ep
can you confirm there is a full
solid record that is in the works yes
100 i think we're aiming for end of
summer
um and i i couldn't be more excited i
put out my first song at 13
currently 18 so over the past five years
it's been like a process of
growing up you can expect just honesty
i think um you can expect a guy that's
pretty unsure
of the world around him and you can
expect somebody that's probably going
through a lot of the same things that
you are and i hope to be open about that
and not be somebody that tries to
sugarcoat my life and make it seem like
something it's not
as a songwriter what are you writing
music about
relationships my life uh this project
specifically i think is like
the most real look into my thought
process whether that's heartbreak
whether that's
um dealing with my upbringing with
adoption and dealing with that before
even all this started so
there's a lot of underlying things i
think so fans really have to pay
attention to the lyrics
and and search for these look deeper
yep look deeper you know you you posted
a tick tock
a couple weeks ago reflecting on the
five year anniversary of sweatshirts it
just hit me it's been five years
since sweatshirt era question
when you think back on that song and
that era
what does that mean to you that's like
my childhood
like i'm still in it kind of but like
i look back at here i can wait let's see
i'll bring you with me where are you i'm
in my room right now in virginia
oh you're back home that's the
sweatshirt black
but that's awesome when i look at that
i'm like yo that's
that's baby jacob right there i'm still
baby jacob but
you know now that you're 18 with 18 year
old vision
how do you feel about the song today
well that's my baby
sweatshirt i love sweatshirt it
definitely got a mixed reaction from
people
but that has helped me in the long run
more than anybody could ever know like
looking back at that i just remember how
far
i've come since then and a lot of
memories but at the same time
yeah i hope to uh take that little kid
to the moon
like i think at this point uh i can't
look at it and say like
you know that's my best work i'm i'm
most proud of this new single and this
upcoming project
but you know looking back of course i
see
a lot of similarities but at the same
time like yeah it's it's progressed a
lot
are you able to have a personal life are
you able to
kind of let loose enjoy do the normal
things that an 18 year old does
surprisingly yeah i live a pretty normal
life i like hanging with my friends i
spend time with my family and
i have fun do you have time to date are
you able to balance
finding romance with all this you know
cool music work that you've got going on
currently no like currently i'm single
and i'm not really
if you listen to the project you
understand that like i'm in a place of
kind of being okay on my own
and um to be honest sometimes i just
have to remind myself that life's all
good i'm happy with me
you're still really young but do you
think about ever
you know settling down one day getting
married having a family of your own
that's the goal yeah like it's hard to
see but like
i hope to uh get married have kids
maybe adopt kids because of how that's
uh
like affected me and i think yeah
just i i think what's gonna mean a lot
to me in the future
is like being a good dad to a kid so
that's definitely like on my bucket list
i think every little move that you make
on the internet you know your fans are
very much
zeroed in on and you went on instagram
live earlier this year
your old pal millie bobby brown she slid
into the comments saying what up jacob
fans were really excited to see that you
guys are still seemingly cool are you
guys still in touch
yeah somewhat and that's that's like one
of my best friends
so she's amazing i wish her nothing but
happiness
that's all what did you learn from that
experience
i learned i guess how to be the best
version of myself
and i'd say that she's an amazing girl
and
i wish her nothing but happiness like
she she's like truly an amazing person
i think loving anybody it teaches you a
lot about yourself
so i'd just say that yeah when we first
met you
you were 13 on what was it it was on you
now where you started correct
yeah yeah that's that's cool you know
that of course
and then now to see you as a super
successful
independent artist you're also huge on
social media
what do you what do you want fans to
know about jacob today
versus the jacob that they first met
back when you were 13. my only goal is
just to hopefully relate to people
whether it's through music social media
anything i'm just
you know i'm just out here just trying
to hopefully
make somebody's day a little better
through different forms of entertainment
and i'll and i'll keep i'll keep
experimenting with different forms
of entertainment i think i can say this
i shot a movie
um i can't go i really can't go into
detail but i did shoot a movie a little
bit ago
and i don't know any more info do fans
know this
is this new information some some of
like the core
like my homies they know but
not like not like everybody this is like
the first time i'm really saying that
i mean congratulations i was lucky i was
blessed to be a part and uh
i'll talk further about that as those
details come out
what else is left on the bucket list do
you have things on your
you know hypothetical or maybe real
vision board
um that you'd love to achieve as you
continue to you know grow and evolve
yeah 100 um
there's music acting social media
and then i'd love to try stand-up comedy
one day like i really think
maybe i'd have fun doing that i'd love
to like take classes it just like that's
always been something that like has been
a fear of mine
but i've never like faced a fear
and then been mad at myself and so
i just i always do this thing where i'm
just like i just have to believe and
have full faith
and try new things because that's i'll
feel better about myself after i fail
at trying something believe it or not
because at least i know what happens if
i try it
is it a goal to win a grammy oh most
definitely yes
sounds crazy but i really do think at
some point it
[Applause]
[Music]